اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ بالمسألة الأكثر إلحاحا
وهي هذه
الهجمات الأمريكية والبريطانية على الحوثيين أه
يبدو أن الولايات المتحدة
تنجر إلى صراع سيكون من
الصعب جدا إعلان النصر
على الحوثيين منذ 10 سنوات
الغارات الجوية السعودية قصف حرب
وما يفعلونه هو إطلاق
طائرات بدون طيار رخيصة الثمن التي تسبب كل هذا
الضرر هل هناك احتمال أن
تنجح هذه الضربات الأمريكية والبريطانية
ربما أه 10% من 100 أه
أعتقد أن السؤال الكبير نجح  هو أن
إدارة بايدن تنجرف
إلى رمال
الشرق الأوسط المتحركة وأعينها مفتوحة على مصراعيها، وقد
مررنا بذلك من قبل، لكن دعونا
نحلل موقف بايدن لمدة
دقيقة منذ اليوم الأول بعد هجمات حماس الدموية
على إسرائيل في السابع من الشهر نفسه.  أكتوبر
أوبا كان الهدف الرئيسي
لإدارة بايدن هو منع
التصعيد وانتشار الصراع
من غزة، ماذا يعني أنه يعني
إعطاء إسرائيل الوقت والمساحة
لإنجاز مهمتها مع منع
وردع أي مجموعة أو دولة من
تقديم المساعدة حقًا لإسرائيل.  لقد
فشلت هذه الإستراتيجية بالنسبة للفلسطينيين، لقد
انتشرت الحرب في غزة على نطاق واسع،
وهي تتصاعد
وتتصاعد لدرجة أن خوفي هو
أنه كلما طال أمد الحرب في غزة،
زاد خطر نشوب
صراع على مستوى المنطقة، وإدارة بايدن
مسؤولة جزئيًا عن ذلك.  لهذا لأنه
يمتلك حقًا مفتاح حل هذه
الأزمة تحديدًا من خلال الموافقة على
وقف إطلاق النار الإنساني الذي ظل معظم
العالم يدعو إليه أه خلال
الأشهر الثلاثة الماضية أو نحو ذلك، دعني أسألك
عن الجزء الآخر الذي
ذكر وهو
حزب الله ما الذي يحتمل أن يحدث
عندما بدأ الصراع،
أدلى رئيس الحسبة بنوع من
التصريح اللافت للنظر حيث بدا وكأنه
يقول أتمنى لكم التوفيق لحماس، لم نكن
نعرف عن هذا مقدما أم لكننا
لا نأخذ نحن لا ننضم لذلك
كان هناك تحذير كان هناك
براغماتية أه هل تعتقد أن حزب الله
يمكن أن ينجذب أكثر لأنه
يبدو أن الأمور
تتغير كما تعلم فريد أه أنت
تتحدث عن القائد أوه حسن لا  لقد
أوضح جدًا في
خطابات متعددة أنه لا يريد حقًا
حربًا شاملة مع إسرائيل لقد أوضح
جدًا أنه لا يوجد حقًا um U
يعني أه قيادة مركزية لمختلف
مجموعات المقاومة في المنطقة
لقد قال جدًا  انظر بوضوح نحن
ندعم بعضنا البعض وننسق مع
بعضنا البعض ولكن لا توجد في الواقع أه
قيادة مركزية وسيطرة أه كل واحد
منا يقول اقتباس غير الاقتباس يتصرف بشكل أساسي
وفقًا
لمصلحته الوطنية وفي الواقع الولايات المتحدة
نفسها أوضحت ذلك تمامًا  إن
الحسبة كانت تتصرف بضبط النفس،
ولم تستهدف
المراكز السكانية في إسرائيل، ولكن إذا
نظرت إلى ما يحدث في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية، فإن
إسرائيل هي التي
تدفع الحسبة إلى أقصى الحدود التي
تستفزها، وهي تقتل كبار
قادتها.  في الميدان قد
هاجم حزب الله في قلب
قاعدته الاجتماعية في بيروت والجنوب
وقتل العشرات من عناصر الحسبة في
سوريا في الأشهر الثلاثة الماضية 19
مقاتلا أكثر مما كان عليه في الماضي أه 20
العام الماضي أم و ال  الولايات المتحدة
مرعوبة مرعوبة وتحاول فعلا
الضغط على إسرائيل حتى لا أه
تستفز ح إسرائيل أيضا أه نجحت ووزارة
الدفاع
وزارة الدفاع الأمريكية غاضبة استهدفت
الجيش اللبناني 34 مرة في
الأشهر الثلاثة الماضية وإذا سألت  لي ما
يحدث هنا وأنا ربما
قد أبدو ساخرًا جدًا ولكن
أعتقد أن المستقبل السياسي لرئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
يعتمد على استمرار الحرب
في غزة وربما توسيعها
لأنه عندما تصمت المدافع في
غزة فهو يعلم أنها  سوف نقوم
بحساب الحساب العام
الحساب العام لفشله الاستراتيجي في
السابع من أكتوبر ولفشله في الوفاء
بوعوده، أعني دعنا
نجري تقييمًا للآخر، دعني
فقط أسألك عنا قبل أن نذهب، على الرغم من
أنني أريد ذلك  أسألك عن هذا
الخبر الآخر وهو أن السعوديين
أكدوا مجددًا أنهم يريدون تطبيع
العلاقات مع إسرائيل، وهو ما يذهلني لأنه أمر
غير معتاد بالنظر إلى كل ما يحدث،
ما رأيك في ما الذي تقرأه في هذا،
هل يفعلون ذلك، إنهم لا يفعلون ذلك
حقًا  لا تهتم بالقضية الفلسطينية
كيف ستقرأها جيدًا والجزء
الآخر الذي لم تذكره
هو أنهم لن يقوموا
بالتطبيع إلا عندما تقبل إسرائيل
السماح للفلسطينيين بتقرير المصير
ودولة
خاصة بهم  لكن انظر في نهاية المطاف، فإن التطبيع من أعلى إلى
أسفل مع المستبدين العرب
لن يمنح أمن إسرائيل
الأمن الوحيد الذي يمكن أن تحصل عليه إسرائيل
وهو المصالحة الحقيقية مع
الفلسطينيين. المصالحة الحقيقية مع
الفلسطينيين تعني إنهاء
الاحتلال العسكري الإسرائيلي، وتعني السماح
للفلسطينيين بتقرير المصير.  هذا يعني
أن تكون مواطنًا صالحًا في جوارها
وأن تكون في سلام مع نفسها. هذه هي
الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكن لإسرائيل أن تعيش بها
بسلام في المنطقة وليس مع هذا
التطبيع المزيف مع المستبدين العرب
الذين لن يوفروا أبدًا
أمنًا حقيقيًا حقيقيًا لإسرائيل.